reason TV now dives into recent magazine
the 45th anniversary edition is now
yours and we're talking with Matt Welch
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine and
Katherine Maggie Ward she's the managing
editor and this devil issue features the
45 enemies of freedom and that's on the
cover that's what you tease inside why
enemies of freedom well ten years ago
for a 35th anniversary issue we had 35
heroes of freedom so people like Milton
Friedman obviously in Dennis Rodman so
we figured 10 years later things have
gotten a little bit dark of late so
let's talk a little bit more about
enemies of freedom and it was a way to
talk about some of the people who are
kind of getting in the way of the world
being more interesting yeah you have
Osama bin Laden Michael Bloomberg you
have Robert Mugabe on there was
certainly an enemy and freedom how did
you put the list together Katherine so
it was a super scientific process in
which we polled reasons staffers about
the people that they hate and then we
eliminated all of their ex-girlfriends
and other personal vendettas and then we
had this fantastic list of 45 and you've
got some some great names on here some
surprises Jenny McCarthy how is she an
enemy of freedom she's a Playboy model
she's also been one of the most vocal
people spreading the myth that vaccines
don't work and people have taken this
and have died as a result of basically
nothing in vaccine and Katherine you
have a degree in philosophy I see John
Rawls is on there how is he an enemy of
freedom and was that your pick
it was my pick I confessed to putting
John Rawls on list and he's it's
actually all his fault I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that you know Michael
Bloomberg took our number one spot but
Rawls could easily have been there he
provided all of the kind of
philosophical underpinnings of modern
political philosophy and modern liberal
thought in particular the ideas that the
whole state should be structured around
equality rather than Liberty or rights
yes and this notion of justice which is
very deeply flawed and obviously one of
your picks is Jeffrey Loria the owner of
the Florida Marlins yeah big art dealer
guys super duper rich apartments in
Manhattan he bought
Marlon's about 10 years ago and he has
been systematically lying to the City
and County of Miami and Dade and Florida
trying to get tons and tons of subsidies
basically he's got 3.4 billion dollars
worth of public money when all will be
said and done to finance his stadium
which then immediately after he got his
fancy stadium he sold off all the best
players in the team there in the last
place he's just a smug jerk in his
really bad taste in art well there are
other articles in the magazine of course
an interesting journey to North Korea
tell me about Michael Mallis and what he
saw there because we've seen in some
travel books that they glorify these
places and it's not a glorified look
it's very honest look so Michael malice
is a pretty weird character he's a
professional ghostwriter and he actually
went over with the idea to possibly
gather some material for a fake ghost
written autobiography of a Dear Leader
or two but what he came back with was
this travelogue for us which included
kind of getting to know his tour guide
and seeing what life is really like to
the extent that you can on one of these
tightly controlled trips the one kind of
I think really interesting point in
there is it's not it's not frozen in
time in the way that we might think it's
frozen in many times so it's actually
the horrors of 80s pantsuits and of the
horrors of 1950s style technology and
the horrors of you know military and you
know sort of speech and thought
oppression and lastly I mean you're a
huge music fan Cuba has always been the
reigning leader Mambo has always been
the sounds that we think of wringing out
of the Caribbean but in fact Jamaica has
taken the crown part of what the issue
looks at is how's the world change since
1968
since reason was started in May of 1968
and one of the interesting ways is that
Havana which has always been the
cultural capital of the Caribbean and
exported Mambo and salsa and other
things under communism they choked off
all of this freedom to create they
choked off record production obviously
they put all artists on the on the
public dole in a way and that kind of
that kind of domesticated them meanwhile
Jamaica had just become independent and
started this very an archaic
musical system which got into ska and
eventually developed reggae so that you
had what was previously a backwater in
Kingston was a global music capital by
the late 60s and early 70s while Cuba
kind of withered away into
insignificance even though the music
that Cuba had launched meanwhile took
off in in the rest of the Caribbean in
the United States it's a real sad story
about a country that once was very very
rich in terms of cultural production
alright so there you go freedom from
many different angles a lot to read in
this double issue so pick it up now Matt
and Katherine thank you very much
and you are a hero to freedom just for
being here for reason TV I'm Kennedy
[Music]